[Musique]
la Continental c'est un acteur
historique du territoire qui évidemment
est extrêmement important en termes
d'emprise à la fois territoriale de
nombre d'emplois ça a été à la fois des
orglorieuses et puis des moments qui ont
été plus difficiles quand des emplois
ont été supprimés donc là je crois que
tout le territoire va accueillir avec
beaucoup de fierté cette annonce de
Continental qui ancre définitivement
l'entreprise à Rambouillet dans le
sud-yvelines
[Musique]
500 emplois donc en trois ans alors pas
exclusivement à Rambouillet mais un
certain nombre d'entre eux le seront et
puis des investissements qui sont des
Investissements d'Avenir puisque sont
des emplois sur la recherche et le
développement en particulier sur la
mobilité durable donc ça veut dire que
voilà ce sont des emplois pérennes qui
vont être créés
depuis notamment ce sommet de choses
France on voit que les investissements
internationaux étrangers bien
choisissent c'est le thème évidemment du
sommeil choisissent la France et ça
c'est vraiment une bonne nouvelle et
donc en tant que parlementaire
évidemment on est là pour accompagner
soutenir devancer aussi un petit peu ces
projets mais là ce sera pas une friche
industrielle c'est au contraire un site
qui va pleinement revivre et retrouver
son activité et autour de cette
entreprise ma permanence est quasiment
juste à côté donc je connais bien ce
site et ce secteur d'activité vous avez
aussi un effet d'entraînement qui peut
exister c'est ça qui est très important
c'est non seulement un site mais c'est
ensuite tous les faits d'entraînement
que ça peut avoir pour tout un bassin de
vie
[Musique]